consider this property off the market
heather ray young and tariq al-musa's
relationship is out of escrow and
officially official
finally
the real estate moguls tied the knot
after two years of dating and
cohabitating the pair started living
together just four days into their
relationship back in 2019 before getting
engaged last july back then heather
dished to et on how shocked she was by
the proposal listen i know you're
thrilled this is a dream come true how
does it feel for it to be here you knew
this was gonna happen since the moment
you met this man you know i didn't know
when though we've we've talked about
marriage throughout dating the last year
but it was never like something
we never talked about it like seriously
like we dabbled in it we talked a little
bit about like oh where would we want it
and but
actually like the last few months he's
been talking more and more about it but
i still i didn't think he was going to
do it on our one-year anniversary i
thought he was gonna wait maybe like you
know a couple months after and um
so i was actually very very shocked and
very surprised
along with a new husband heather is also
scoring a bonus family officially
becoming a stepmom to targ's two
children taylor and braden who he shares
with ex-wife and fellow flipper flop
star christina hack when you get into a
relationship with a man who already has
a family it's it's so much more
difficult than any just dating someone
so have you talked to the kids like what
are their thoughts oh yeah well he
actually told his daughter taylor four
days before he proposed so uh the day
they went back to their mom's house i
was here making breakfast for the kids
and he had taylor upstairs and pulled
her into our room and he's like honey i
have the biggest secret you can't tell
anyone i need you to be a big girl and
so he told her he really wanted her
involved because
you know they're like best friends are
super close and i adore her she adores
me we're super close to and he knew that
she'd want to know and be involved so
she kept that secret and she's talked
about me marrying him throughout our
whole relationship heather and tark also
revealed to et in july that wedding
planning was kind of a breeze we haven't
really had any hiccups i'm not stressed
i'm more stressed about other things but
wedding i'm just so excited i'm ready
we're excited we're ready we're so ready
has it been easier because things are
getting back to normal to plan a wedding
absolutely i think less stress and now
that we know that everything's getting
back to normal no one has to worry about
anything so
it was stressful while we were trying to
figure out a location but that's locked
in everything's good and we're just
excited and lucky for us we'll
definitely be getting a glimpse of the
wedding planning process when heather's
show selling sunset returns to netflix
this fall i'm actually
involving on the show i'm having my
bridal shower on the show
uh we're having a joint bachelor
bachelorette party i don't think it's
gonna be film because it's gonna be a
little you know
okay um but yeah i'm talking about the
wedding and also on his show flipping
101.
yeah it's the crossover we never knew we
needed yeah who would have thought we
would have thought right right so target
we'll see you on selling sets at this
upcoming season oh yes you will yeah
finally i know people are so excited um
obviously i think a lot of people binged
it during quarantine what do you want
fans to know about the upcoming season
like on a scale from 1 to 10 how much
drama will there be 11 12 13 14 15. 900.
i'm i mean i'm asked my future husband
how stressed am i
it's been a rough season i think the
fans are going to be excited yeah